the Joe Rogan experience I think I need
some of those pills he's not as
dosterone yeah he's some trt is that
legal
Oh a hundred percent yeah I think I need
someone I need a detail some of that
yeah dude I've been on that show for ten
years
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah you make it a bunch of
different ways now to theirs they were
making the spray for a while like it was
like under the tongue
you could put drops in and then I don't
know if they're doing that anymore but
they have a cream the cream is good but
if you hug people
it gets on them it's weird wait where do
you rub it on you rub it on your chest
to your arms so if you sex with your
wife your wife's arm might grow a
mustache well you find very strange that
would be like a really creepy way if you
were like really into dudes but you were
married to a woman yeah how do i how do
i bridge this gap like I'm on trt and
you would rub it all over your chest and
immediately get on her and the [ __ ] are
you doing
give her protein shakes make good at the
gym a lot yeah yeah hey honey you look
at with short hair put her under stress
to make her work more there's something
that happens with women apparently there
was a study on career women and they
don't know if it's a correlation or
causation thing because maybe the reason
why they were career women in the first
place because they had a lot of
testosterone but they were there notice
that women have to fend for themselves
women have to take care of themselves
they generally have more testosterone
interesting which makes sense but
doesn't I you never know like what came
first the chicken or the egg is that
like who they are are they developing
more testosterone because they're they
have to be out there competing yeah you
know yeah I I remember I was uh
i d--'s Rogaine for a while I was
actually I got approached by my agent
and he goes um you got an offer to do a
commercial series of commercials I said
for what he goes Rogaine I go but I
don't my hair is not thinning and he's
like yeah so it's five commercials I was
in denial about it I was like 29 and I
guess I was starting to crown a little
bit but I didn't notice and so he goes
do you want to do it I was like I don't
know
I'm about to move out to LA I want to
maybe do some acting I don't want to be
seen maybe on TV is the Rogaine guy and
he's like I talked to them and they said
it's only gonna it's gonna be on like
ESPN 4 at 2:00 in the morning don't
worry whatever and I go and I go all
right [ __ ] I move in LA I got no
money I'll do it I'll get health
insurance out of it I'm about to get
married
so I record the commercials and the
tagline is it's me and a pharmacy and
I'm looking at a bottle and it's MoDOT
minoxidil v they just jacked it up from
3 to 5 and I go 4 out of 5 the voice
over goes four out of five doctors say
this will work and then I go I look at
the camera I go 4 out of 5 I like my
chances so I do it I do it and then
there is there's that guy I like nod yes
legit so they so all of a sudden it
starts running it runs during the
[ __ ] playoffs
March Madness every guy I've ever met
was calling me and gone I like my I'm
walking down the street I like my
chances it was everywhere yeah and so
they gave me they gave me a [ __ ]
supply for years and I was using it and
I would my wife wouldn't let me cuddle
with her because she don't you put on
your head at the end of the before you
go to bed cuddle up next to her again
she could [ __ ] hair on her neck oh
and it made you all greasy my pillows
were all greasy and all it really grew
was like a [ __ ] fuzz yeah did you ever
try that [ __ ] I tried that [ __ ] I tried
everything yeah yeah I wish I shaved my
head way earlier it's so easy I think
I'm gonna do it tomorrow for the first
out of my life once I shaved my head I
was like why am i [ __ ] around with
all his hair yeah if I had I had full
head of hair I'd shave my [ __ ] head
I'd shaved my head like every two weeks
I just let it grow too stubble and then
shave it down again let it grow too
stubble it's like it's so much easier
how often do you shave it every couple
days you take a razor and she's about
yea easy I have one that has like it's
made for shaving your head
like a handle on it it's like an
electric razor just one round could so
you don't miss any spots
how long is it taking a couple minutes
you feel good yeah that's great I don't
have to think about it that's what I
like I don't know this I don't think
about this I used to worry about my hair
when my hair was falling out when
something's out of your control four
people have a full head of hair they
really don't understand this when you
start losing your hair young Jaime son
of a [ __ ] well you start losing your
hair you you just go oh my god like
there's nothing you're gonna do about
this this is terrible like there's
nothing you can do and then you look at
like these [ __ ] guys like some guys
that are like gross looking bald dudes
and you look oh my god they used to be a
kid yeah they used to be just like me
and then one day it all [ __ ] fell out
and they were this gross dude with the
horseshoe around the bottom of the head
like what the [ __ ] that's what I'm gonna
be
and once you shave your head like for me
I got lucky I have a good shape
[Applause]